[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone surprise surprise we got
some brand new Rick and Morty to break
down we also have some Rick and Morty's
season 5 this early I'll explain why
that is because typical live-action
production shows have a different
schedule than animated shows but Rick
and Morty has that 70 episode order so
they're just rolling through production
so of course they're already starting to
talk about what's going on during season
5 and the stories they'll do dan harmon
posted a whole bunch of really funny
season 5 stuff from their writers room
they actually just moved to a really big
office I think it just because in
success they're getting a much better
office than they had before if you've
ever seen the Rick and Morty offices so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Rick and Morty
videos it's coming back this November of
course I'm going to be doing episode
videos for it there's probably gonna be
a big Comic Con panel where they'll drop
an animatic or an official teaser this
summer that's a cold open but this is
obviously just them doing the uber
version of the more Pfizer XE that you
saw from season 3 where summer blew
herself up boob hostile oh yeah what do
you have in common with Tricia Lang a
mutual love of French cinema the belief
that a carbon tax was the only viable
solution to climate change or could it
be her massive stripper titties there it
is
boob yeah this would be one of those
pack up your [ __ ] kind of moments where
it just packs this stuff up and heads to
another reality I told you Morty we can
only do this a couple more times but
these are all the funny story ideas for
Rick and Morty season 5 the Dan Harmon
was posting so I'll explain why they're
doing season 5 stuff right now in a
second but some of these are actually
pretty funny so all these are just
pitches for what the basic concept of an
episode would be about what the story's
about so we start with artificial person
with a real leg Rick discovers the 11th
commandment this one has a thumbs up
from Dan Harmon in the picture just
because he said it's one of his
favorites Maximum Overdrive
but with grass if you've never seen
Maximum Overdrive it's this 80s Stephen
King cult classic movie that he directed
himself based on a short story the story
is about a bunch of machines coming to
life and going around killing people one
of them being a really giant 18-wheeler
truck that comes after emilio estevez
this is one of those ideas in the vein
of Mad Max beyond the thunderdome makes
with cannibals like they did during that
season three episode two story hey you
guys ever use that Thunderdome or do you
just put it up for decoration
uh you mean the Blood dome save it for
the semantics domi be white then there's
planet of no stop signs trench coat made
of dreams the people's basketball court
wesley sniper that most beaks for itself
when wolf instead of werewolf Voltron
but with vegetables I actually kind of
liked that one it seems like a follow up
idea to pickle Rick Rick turning himself
into different vegetables the reason
anyone would do this if they could which
they can't would be because they could
which they can't library of food maybe
this ready to cope with some of these
ideas while they were getting really
hungry waiting for their lunches to
arrive woman made of fish Jerry gets a
pine cone stuck in his butt which sounds
like something that Jerry would do we
won't ask him how he got the pine cone
in his butt to begin with and what he
was trying to do with it in the first
place detachable fingers or toes anal
beads I'll let you decide which
character would actually bring that into
the story like who's gonna be walking
around with something like that in their
pocket planet powered by chips and salsa
that idea just sounds delicious
Morty buys a boat bark nado that sounds
like a cephalus equal to the season one
episode where he and his dog kind went
to another planet
where are my testicles summer planet of
the Hodags if you don't know what Hodag
is it's based on this 1890s conspiracy
theory that was drummed up as this fake
animal that someone found in the wild
sort of like a manbearpig situation it
was a creature that newspapers purported
had the head of a frog the grinning face
of a giant elephant thick short legs set
off by huge claws the back of a dinosaur
in the long tail was Spears at the end
big surprise it turned out to be this
huge hoax but this is all happening back
in the 1890s so over a hundred years ago
but the sheer concept of an animal like
that doesn't seem that out of place in a
Rick and Morty episode next story idea
was blood shed as in a shed full of
blood that sounds like some sort of
crazy Hellraiser idea invisible pigs
don't know what they're gonna do with
that watch where you step there poop is
also invisible then the last one that I
can make out on this table here is Jiri
makes a log-cabin with hair which sounds
like something really stupid that Jerry
would try to do but let me know if you
can actually read any of the text on any
of these notes that I didn't mention in
the video so a lot of these probably
won't wind up being episodes just
because if they actually were going to
turn these ideas into episodes they
wouldn't have spoiled them by posting
them on social media but it's just a
good idea for the way that they come up
with concepts for episodes just a really
crazy spitballing that they then turn
into an actual script like while you
were doing this I solved the middle-east
Burns's breeches [ __ ] comes to a head
but if you guys have been seeing Justin
roiland posting recently on social media
he's getting ready to go to e3 to
promote his new VR video game through
his video game companies squash games
called trover saves the universe if
we're lucky we might catch him doing
interviews about the game also answering
questions about Rick and Morty season 4
characters and stories so if there's any
big news that comes out of e3 about Rick
and Morty I'll totally do a video about
it but the reason why they're talking
about Season 5 stories right now at this
time of the year is because the typical
production style for a live-action
Network show that airs during the
traditional times of the year is that
around this time of year their writers
room is getting ready to go on hiatus
for a few weeks then they come back
during the summer to write and shoot
episodes that will air later in the year
the
production cycle for animation from
script to screen is way longer which is
why there was such a huge delay between
Rick and Morty season 2 in Rick and
Morty season 3 but they would only be
having these season 5 story meetings if
they had finished all their stories for
season 4 at least come up with the ideas
and sent them off to animation or they
were in the script phase already and
writers were actually just banging them
out usually what happens is is once they
come up with a story idea they'll give
it to a writer after they come up with a
concept for what the episode is actually
gonna be they go off and write it they
bring it back they give notes then
eventually they'll send it to animatic
then that animatic will actually go to
be animated so this just confirms my
low-grade conspiracy theory that all
their season 4 episodes are either in
animation or getting ready to go to
animation meaning that they'll actually
be done way sooner than November which
is when season 4 is actually premiering
this year Rick and Morty is back brand
new season 4 in November 2019 this year
we're gonna do it this year 2019 man I
can't believe we're back there a couple
big reasons why they would do something
like that but I think mostly is they can
get ahead of their production schedule
because they have those 70 episodes so
they can just keep rolling through
production as fast as possible so there
isn't a giant delay between Rick and
Morty season 4 and Rick and Morty season
5 in fact they're this far ahead of next
year's production schedule then they
might even be able to get episodes for
season 5 out by the summer but what they
might do is they might just choose to
keep Rick and Morty on a one-year
schedule and keep it in the fall or in
the spring
just because networks typically earn
more advertising dollars when they
premiere episodes during those times of
the year than when they do during the
summer and because Rick and Morty earned
so much of its extra money on
merchandise what a big surprise that
they're airing season four right before
Black Friday during the holiday shopping
season later this year you guys we got a
hurry I just got back from Walmart
they're selling in Tendo 3d systems for
one $49.99 on sale plus every time you
buy one you get a $50 gift card brings
the total price down $110 after-tax so
if it's really successful and they
earned way more money on Rick and Morty
season four than they have on previous
seasons they might just choose to
continue keeping it around that time of
the year they've already talked about a
couple of season four story ideas that
they held over from season three they
haven't said if it's going to be 10
episodes or
13 episodes per season but Adult Swim
can air as many or as few episodes as
they want per season but Dan Harmon
Justin run will just roll through
production on all 70 then Adult Swim
will just decide when they're gonna air
those episodes if you're a child of the
80s or a little bit older you may
remember Batman and the animated series
was part of that big Fox production
block that they aired in the afternoon
programming Fox basically did the same
thing that Adult Swim did with Rick and
Morty they ordered 90 episodes from
Warner Brothers of batman the animated
series so bruce timm and all the people
on the show produced all those batman
the animated series episodes and then
Fox just broke it up into a couple
different seasons just airing episodes
when they wanted to if you have any big
questions or big requests for Rick and
Morty bonus videos while we're waiting
for season four to get here let me know
in the comments I just did a new Avatar
The Last Airbender Netflix series video
we got a teaser you can click here to
watch that and you can click here for my
other Rick and Morty season 4 teaser
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome we'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]